so John first of all the white paper you
weren't over impressed or necessary so I
wasn't overly impressed I think it's a
white paper with a tinge of green really
it seems to have a lot of consultation
written within the paper which I think
that consultations do back in May so
it's a little bit light on detail I
would say having said that there's some
good things in there I think we're very
supportive of perhaps increasing
resources in planning departments albeit
we've got to pay more for playing fees
to do so I think it's good that they've
said that they're trying to reduce the
number of conditions that are attached
to planning permissions and I think
they're really trying to put pressure on
local authorities to put local plans in
place and to test them to make sure
they're delivering on those local plans
so I think although that's good for us
but we'll just have to wait and see how
that evolves into legislation really did
you like the fact that they kept talking
about the housing market being broken no
I didn't actually I didn't like the
title at all and I thought it was a
little bit headline-grabbing
I think if you look at what the industry
is done over recent years it's increased
the output by 50% in the last three
years of so so I hardly think that's a
broken housing market right in terms of
some of the specific provisions that you
just talked about I mean one of them I
guess one of the most eye-catching ones
was this fact that if you own land and
planning permissions being granted
you're now gonna have to build on it in
two years rather than the current three
I mean is that something you can live
with yeah it is basically I mean when we
get an implementable planning permission
we were on site as soon as we can get on
site so for us you know it's a matter of
months
I suppose my concern is at what point is
that going to to apply because you know
if it's outlined then you've still got
to get a reserve mat as approval you
still look at conditions clear so a lot
of that could lay in the hands of the
local authority as to how quick they are
if it applies that the reserve matter
stage I don't think we'll have too much
to worry about I mean they are as you
say holding local authorities feet to
the fire to an extent as well I mean you
take comfort for that presumably well
okay look at look at their track record
I mean one of the things I think the
paper mentions it and they were asked to
get the local plans in place by last
year giving an extension to this year
and still 60 percent of Lok
authorities have not got a five-year
plan in place so you know they deserve
to really be pushed hard on trying to
set their plan so that we can get
housing under way one thing that I think
would have surprised a lot of people
which came out yesterday was that sixty
percent of all new homes in the UK are
built by just ten builders of whom you
are you are one does there need to be
more variety in the ecosystem yeah I
think I think you will see that one of
the reasons that housing output has
probably dropped over over the years is
because of the demise of some of the
small and medium sized house builders
and I think the house Home Builders
Federation did a good piece of work
recently they published and basically
said that if we had the same number of
small and medium sized house builders
now that we had in 2007 there would be
twenty five thousand more homes built so
you can see where the issue lies really
but I mean the fact that SME there are
fewer SME builders and actually you've
announced today you've taken out Radley
homes as well I mean you're batted to
the concentration in the sector yeah but
I think if you look at our track record
and on output and growth and what we
intend to do with Radley is actually
probably get more out of that business
than they would have been able to do
themselves because of the constraints on
businesses of that scale so so I think
in many ways you know if I read Roe
taking over Radley we're able to expand
that business much more quickly than it
would have been able to do so on it on
its own so what are the other kind of
obstacles that stand in the way of
smaller builders gaining momentum and
becoming bigger and more competitive
well I think what's happened over and I
mean the demise has been going on for
twenty years and it's really about the
barriers to entry and principally of
course those are planning it's more
complex to get planning it's more
expensive to get planning there are
conditions to satisfy there's more
technical inquiries in terms of ecology
archaeology and the like so it's made it
much harder for the smaller builders and
of course you know they used to be the
ones that were building back gardens but
so you know I could remind this
government who were part of the
coalition in 2010 they stopped this
garden grabbing which was a good source
of land for small builders now looking
at your results today you've said that
you expect
to be 1.9 billion a year by 2019 I mean
clearly you you're anticipating no
slowdown in demand or growth whatsoever
in the next couple of years no we're
pretty confident about the future we've
got a good pipeline of sites that coming
through which will support that growth
we also have a record order book we've
got nine nearly nine hundred million in
forwards sales which some of that takes
us right into 2019 so I think off the
back of having a good pipeline of sites
having a strong order book economy yes
it might be a little bit bumpy I guess
over the next twelve months or so but we
were pretty confident the market will be
there and support those growth plans and
very briefly John we've got this vote
going through the Commons this evening
on whether you Nationals will be able to
stay in the UK post brexit could could
your business operating the way it does
at the moment with the ho-tu Nationals
and you labor I think parts of the
business would find it difficult
particularly in London where there's a
big reliance upon a new labor and
something needs to be done about that
all right John touch from retro thanks
for joining me
long day for you appreciate it